we do indeed we are here with wander
liang after a devastating victory
against carissa i wonder first of all
you came into the studio and i could see
it on your face you're still harboring
some disappointment from previous rounds
tell us about that yeah after the first
two games i thought it was normal just
a bad tournament which happens from time
to time um
after yesterday i i was sure that um
someone maybe abi abhimanyu
sacrificed a few years of their life to
take a few games from me because i was
just like okay there's no way this is
happening um
but but yeah i mean i think it's it's
fine i mean it happens every once in a
while i think i've i probably haven't
started this poorly in
um almost like a decade so
it's like a once-in-a-lifetime event and
um
yeah okay i'll get it out of my system
after this event and hopefully it'll be
better from there well still plenty of
rounds to go but how do you deal with uh
that disappointment how do you just put
it to the side
um yeah i'm not sure if it's up to
standard with the dress code but um i
decided it was dire measures so i
decided to bring my lucky hoodie with me
i don't think i've lost the game with
this hoodie in like four years so dire
so i mean it ended up working pretty
well i think um yeah the game was pretty
short absolutely let's talk about
today's game you came up with this idea
of bishop to e2 against the kings indian
did you expect karisa to start with the
kings india
yeah i think it's her main opening
pretty standard choice for her
um probably in
like the current state with modern
engines it's a little dubious
yeah i saw she played c6 before
and so yeah origi i was gonna just play
knight f3 in some normal
position but um i analyzed this h4 line
like for some bullet games and at the
board it's just yeah probably it was a
bad decision but i couldn't help myself
i just go for this h45 i mean i think
the engine says it's decent but nothing
spectacular probably black can hold
um yeah i wasn't sure about knight h7
pro probably i was just misremembering
something i thought maybe 98 is the move
um
but yeah either way i think it's
it's pretty much fine for black i mean
some slight advantage for white nothing
serious
um yeah in the game probably i i mix
something up because i couldn't recall
what to do after hg
and
probably i should just take on f7 and
take on g4 and that way at least i'm not
done no actually bishop takes g4 was the
right move okay okay so yeah i i i
wasn't really sure what's going on okay
i see f5 is also a mistake um
did you feel like she was out of her
theoretical knowledge or
she still knows something here i thought
it's very unlikely that she knows
anything too serious um actually here i
was a little bit concerned because i i
missed that after knight h3 bishop s7 h5
black has this move e5 and somehow i
kind of
i don't know yeah my head was sort of in
a weird space but probably it's still
okay for white but
yeah i was
it's a little unpleasant to miss things
like this
and yeah i think the game the way the
game went i
i really wasn't sure but
it probably looks like there's
nice compensation all around like
i think probably b5 was just not a good
move but
um
but okay yeah i see i see the
bar it's already too bad the giveaway
keeps going
so i'm not too sure what she could have
done better in that case yeah probably
not these six i think at that point she
was supposed to uh develop her pieces as
fast as possible 97 if i remember yeah
yeah probably i mean it's hard to say
it's still very difficult right yeah i
mean as long as i'm not like completely
lost in the center like stuff's not
collapsing i think basically it's enough
compensation long-term initiative on the
g4 and right always knight d4 is coming
and it's hard to protect all the pawns
so
absolutely and after the move b5 you
felt like you're in full control yeah
yeah b5 was very strange i i don't know
okay
bar didn't like queen takes d6 but i
thought this end game is just completely
lost for black
there's
yeah there's just no development and
everything's hanging
and you delivered almost a checkmate she
didn't allow you to get the checkmate
but you got the full piece after that
i wonder you're playing uh brandon
jacobson uh top competitor tomorrow uh
with the black pieces how are you going
to strategize that game are you going to
go all in um
yeah okay i actually didn't know i was
playing him so thanks about information
um
yeah i'm not sure it's just another game
i think
yeah we'll just see what happens i
nothing too spectacular probably as soon
as the event is over um this is probably
going to be a good day but
um yeah yeah we'll see i mean it's just
it's just another game so still plenty
to go and uh still a championship to
play for guys any questions yes a wonder
uh you're playing in this tournament and
i always thought think of it as a kind
of a qualifying event to the open
championship but my understanding is
you're already qualified for this coming
u.s championship am i right in thinking
that
um i don't think so no maybe they
updated the rating list and i'm not too
sure i didn't get the invite yet so okay
that's on your guys actually you like it
yeah
but
but either way yeah it's always it's
just good to play some chess um i kind
of skipped some of the other big opens
like the world open in favor of like
this one game a day format and it's good
to be back in st louis
obviously i wish the event could have
been
going a little bit more in the right
direction but
yeah either way um
i mean it's just a good opportunity to
play some chess irregardless of the us
championship qualification spot
all right thank you wonder good luck in
the remaining games uh the right your
ship yeah absolutely good to see him
bounce back with the victories neiman
who qualified that's what i'm thinking
from the junior last year yeah yes yeah